we humans live on earth that we all know
and we can look up at the stars there
are stars that are close to us and there
are stars that are further away
belonging to other galaxies and there
are stars that are extremely far away
belonging to extremely far away galaxies
now for about a century we know that we
see that far away galaxies which are
islands of billions of stars far away
galaxies seem to move away from us we
see that the light that reaches us
coming from those galaxies is what they
were the scientists called redshifted
meaning something has been stretched in
between those galaxies and us what has
been stretched is the distance that
separates us from those galaxies as time
goes by all the distances in space
stretch they expand that's what we call
the expansion of the universe it is not
actually that those faraway stars or
galaxies move away from us it is the
distance in itself that increases there
is more space and time in between them
now than there was before just to make
that point clear that's when you when
you are from on earth and look at the
Stars the expansion of the universe
makes all the faraway galaxies look as
if they were moving away but if you
imagined that you were living somewhere
else in another galaxy far away in the
universe from there all the stars and
galaxies that are far away would again
be moving away from you to summarize the
expansion of the universe means that
distances increase with time that's not
something that is completely crazy to
understand if you imagine that the
universe started with a big bang meaning
that everything we can see in outer
space right now was condensed in a very
much smaller volume a long time ago then
somehow some energy got released and
every
thing expanded okay the universe grew
but if you think about that carefully
what that means is that somehow this
expansion this blow-up this Big Bang
thing should slow down with time when
you have an explosion on earth the
objects that are thrown away they slow
down because there is friction but
because there is something happening
objects don't keep moving and flying
forever they slow down the universe it
should be the same in some sense gravity
should keep things from moving too far
away from one another if there is enough
gravity for instance the expansion
should slow down after a while but there
you go
in 1998 astronomers discovered that it
is actually the other way around
in space looking at faraway galaxies
they realized that the expansion the
rate of expansion is accelerating so
there is a force pushing away the
faraway galaxies faster and faster with
time and that's something that gravity
cannot explain gravity pulls things back
towards one another and this accelerated
expansion means that there is another
force the force that has been called
dark energy this discovery of dark
energy of the accelerated expansion of
our universe did change something
already in the way we picture the future
of our universe for a long time since we
know of the Big Bang there were
basically two possibilities for the
future of our universe the first one is
that there is so much matter in there
that despite the expansion gravity would
work like some kind of rubberband and
would bring everything back into what we
call a Big Crunch that everything will
be pulled towards each other at some
stage and the expansion would go the
other way around and we would have the
the precise opposite as a Big Bang which
was called Big Crunch the discovery of
the accelerated expansion kind of ruled
that possibility
in the sense that gravity will never be
strong enough to pull things back into a
big crunch we are the we are more into a
scenario in which our universe will keep
expanding will keep being getting bigger
and bigger forever that is what we can
expect as of today for the future of our
universe